good morning Hank it's Wednesday in case
you missed the news yesterday I can
finally tell you the title of my new
video title you ruined it
the title was inspired by wine from
Shakespeare's Julius Caesar The Fault
dear Brutus is not in Our Stars but in
ourselves that we are underlings which
is an easy thing to say if you're like
you know Shakespeare or a Roman nobleman
but in the broad sense I don't know that
I agree with jxp R 100% so that's the
title The Fault in Our Stars I actually
kind of stole the title from a
nerdfighter misse-x Rojas on YouTube so
thank you nerd fight area another Thank
You nerdfighteria news these are the top
three best-selling books on Amazon right
now Hank The Fault in Our Stars is
number one on both Amazon and Barnes and
Noble yes I have an exclamation to use
in such situate the llama thank you so
much to everyone who's pre-order the
book there's a link in the doobly-doo
dftba slash T feos it's not a very good
title for shortening at which you can
pre-order the book so you did good boy
it's only like nine dollars also Hank if
you preorder The Fault in Our Stars
there is a 100 percent chance that it
will be autographed by me and when I say
100 percent chance I mean that I am
signing every single copy of the first
printing and I don't mean some machine
is gonna sign it I mean I'm gonna sign
it with my hand also probably a sharpie
speaking of which a couple days ago I
was at Target and I was in the Sharpie
aisle and I was trying to decide like
which sharpie to use for signing these
tens of thousands of books and I had a
bit of an existential crisis because I
was like do I sign it in black sharpie
but if I do that then they might not
even think it's real if I do like blue
or red might be like kind of
ostentatious if I do green they're gonna
think I'm planning on my name so I'm
just gonna delegate this whole sharpie
color fiasco there is a link in the
doobly-doo to a poll in your pants that
sounds dirty
all sewing in the last 24 hours
nerdfighters have made hundreds of
covers for The Fault in Our Stars some
of them really really good in fact there
are so many really really good ones that
I want to show them all to you but I
don't have anything left to say so I'm
just gonna throw you a singer' magic
concert
okay
Oh
god I'm good at dissing magic
so to summarize Hank pre-order link in
the doobly-doo all pre-orders will be
signed thank you so much for making it
the number one bestseller on Amazon and
also for your amazing covers in
retrospect Hank I don't know why I spent
four years writing this book when I
could have just made a hit singer magic
album in other news nerdfighters I don't
know if you started reading The Great
Gatsby but I'm gonna start talking about
it today but I'm only going to talk
about the epigraph and the first
sentence so no spoilers at this way
that's gonna take me like 1,200 videos
to get through the book right so head
you know how pretentious novels like
this one always start with quotes at the
beginning of the book those are called
epigraphs well the great gatsby has a
famous epigraph by the poet thomas park
didn't feel yeah that goes like this
then wear the gold hat if that will move
her if you can bounce high bounce for
her to toe she cry lover gold-hatted
high bouncing lover I must have you so
here's an interesting thing about that
epigraph Frank Thomas Park Denville yay
doesn't exist so two things to remember
about the epigraph one it's made up and
two it contains the word golden twice
both of which are important because
Gatsby is essentially a book about
things that are made up and/or golden so
keep that in mind as you're reading
other things to keep in mind anybody
wearing glasses and the green light god
I love the green light is my favorite
metaphor in any book ever
except maybe Holden's hunting haft and
the last thing I would ask you to notice
is the lyricism of the novel I mean you
can almost hear the rhythm of it from
the first sentence in my younger and
more vulnerable years my father gave me
some advice I've been turning over in my
mind ever since okay now I feel like a
teacher to give you an assignment you
have until two weeks from today to be
the first six chapters of Gatsby and
there will be a quiz and I don't want
any sex all right just to remind you
don't forget about the pull in your
pants I'll see you on Friday